well ADHD affects many of our children
but many adults apparently as well and
a drug that helps
shortage causing
we connected with
with answers as to why this is happening
and what options you have
been something to three different
pharmacies to try to help somebody get
medication Doctrine Childress
specializes in ADHD treatment at the Las
Vegas clinic the center for psychiatric
and Behavioral Medicine she's also the
president of the American professional
Society of ADHD and Related Disorders
and she's been Fielding calls from
concerned clients due to the shortage I
have adults that hey I can't work I
can't focus yeah I'm a you know I worry
about driving because the people are
more likely to have a car accident when
they're not taking medication the FDA
first announced the Adderall shortage in
October of 2022 partly due to some
supply chain issues in manufacturing
delays but it's now being driven by a
rise in consumer demand and a change in
Access in the past people needed to get
a prescription in person but due to the
pandemic providers were allowed to
prescribe the drug after just online
consultations the number of
prescriptions has skyrocketed we're
talking going from 35 million
prescriptions a year to 41 million and
so it's hard to keep up with that demand
she says patients can go on to the fda's
website check the FDA drug shortages app
as well you can see who makes Adderall
the different strengths and whether it's
available or not half the company say
not available some say end of June
children suggest the following I know a
number of the companies they do have
coupons where people can get the
medication it's going to cost them more
than a generic would cost them but they
can get the medication they just need to
be proactive and talk with their doctor
go on to the websites and look at these
new medications
Dr Childress also suggests check out
GoodRx where you can find cheaper
generic Alternatives as well